I want to get into some things you guys
had some some interesting concepts about
how life would change in the new post
Corbett and here are some here's a
couple of thoughts of you guys had here
was a call gang calling from Texas
what's up chief what up chief boy and
you notice fella probably huffing on
that bag you don't get the name chief
these days chief used to be a Native
American superior term if you're a
captain of the Native Americans if you
basically this you know the Chris Pratt
Acharya if he's a real you know if you
that top dog in the in the feather in in
that in that feather Club then you would
get that name chief but more recently
chief is more of a okay you know little
Gary does a lot of chief in that hey
sucking on that gas bro puffing that
that Gugu that herb maybe that that weed
huffing that nasty nasty you know he
huffing that [ __ ] you know mr.
McGregor's gunpowder dog I'm talking
about marijuana I'm talking about that
puff puff I'm talking about that poor
pop to your brain that dope weed onward
I was watching the podcasters [ __ ]
ladies night one whatever the [ __ ] that
was yeah it was ladies night brother
onward watching that [ __ ] just now you
said what do you thinks gonna go away
and the near future talking about
pooping their attempts taking [ __ ] like
that right we're talking about people
last on last episode we're talking about
people getting their temperatures taken
when you go to an event you know you go
somewhere and now in the future might
they might you know take your
temperature check your for snot they
might you know touch your kids low ass
or something see if it's hot see if you
bring it in a little Timothy or whatever
with that
ass because that you can't do it you
can't do that you're not gonna be able
to do that as well you bring in that up
temperature temp temp a--they it's not
gonna go over well with others
let's hear more brother thank you for
the call what's gonna go away I think
you know you're not some tickets like
anger you know but there probably had 10
or 15 makes two restaurants in Louisiana
what's gonna go away though is chips and
queso and chips and salsa sign that [ __ ]
is done homie that's not gonna be on the
menu no more son unless you get it
individually it's not an appetizer no
more you know what I'm saying cuz what
everybody's doing they're getting the
chips bring a chip to the dip putting a
straight in a mouth go back to the chips
going back to the gift went back
straightening mouth damn you know lean
with it rock with it huh no you can't
sanitize every time you touch a chip you
know what I mean them chips you just
want me to stall see after a while so so
yeah all right Peter all right be the
case though in salsa gang gang gang bruh
man wow I hadn't thought about that yeah
yeah you have to each person will have
to bring a couple of their own chips
from home I guess and you know or yeah
uh yeah I don't know what they're gonna
do hmm
but yeah you can't have that group you
can't have that that that swimming pool
in the middle of the table you can't
have that little that little cheese
[ __ ] strip mall in the little of the
table and everybody's just scooping in
getting this picking up a pair of Adidas
or picking up a pair of uh you know
Motorola or something or get some
speakers or some [ __ ] Chinese food
that Chang chopped you know yeah they're
not gonna have that group that little
wah that little um they're not gonna
have that little where everybody's just
the hands are in there just that little
bang bang bang up there with the chips
hmm that's gonna be interesting man yeah
that could be one thing that could go
away now you got to bring a couple chips
from home or something you got to write
you know your name on a chip Darren you
know little
Ricky and little Ricky got four chips
you know when Darren got nine chips
Darren's big-ass got nine chips and
actor actor over there and you know he
you know chips running his family so he
got 40 chips come on Hector no you got
40 chips bro shoot the nine pointer papa
but yeah it's gonna be because everybody
yeah you're not gonna have to be able to
have that that meeting that meet up in
the middle of the table that could be
something could change here's another
thing let's go how things could change
what's up Pete and that's their out of
Central PA and yeah central Pennsylvania
if you want to see the Amish and the
Amish are basically like um they're kind
of like it's like Halloween but it's
kind of like the most boringest
Halloween you ever been to bro and you
got to work the whole time dawg
that's their anyway they have a lot of
Amish in Central PA gang [ __ ] brother
homeward walk in there where they burnt
down the junk and Donna oh yeah up there
samokhin were where they burned down the
Dunkin Donuts Mammoth's [ __ ] damn
experiments oh yeah we used to meet up
at the Dunkin balanced yeah I had me a
um a head of my parole officer sometime
we'd meet up over about a Dunkin donnas
bruh you know I used to you know use the
can in there maybe wash out my pants in
them right gang oh so I just wanted to
call and comment about the you know the
change to the handshake you brought up
on last week's podcast and I came up
with something the other day I think it
might cut John I think I like to call
the et greeting or maybe
I'll stretch that arm stick that finger
out and just just barely touch the tip
that way you know you get a little
greeting but you can also maintain that
social distance and I think it also
might change the meaning of giving
somebody the finger so that's what I got
man love you love the podcast keep doing
your date
thank you brother I appreciate this
message and that's a yeah could the
handshake we talked about that less we
could the handshake change and what you
would do because it does seem like a lot
to give all 10 fingers out to somebody
in a shake so maybe you do that one
finger just that little that et that
just that little touch me that touch me
tender and you also you would know if
the other person is real wasted or not
because you have to touch their finger
if the line fingers up so if their
finger they can't even hit Jers then
you've got us guys all jacked up on
something do ting you know and looked at
bro I didn't know armor and one time a
buddy of mine and he's a young
homosexual fell actually and he's
certified he's certified he'll tell you
he is and he's really he's been with men
and he knows he's uh you know I'm not
I'm just I'm not telling you I'm not
tattling on anybody's wiener you know
this guy's certified you know prefers
homoeroticism and he I remember the day
he told me that he was uh you know he
really loved men like that like
specialty and that he really liked to
hug men and just you know like he liked
to sometimes put his hands up in another
man's shirt while the man still had the
shirt on and things like that and um and
he said oh I remember when he told me I
didn't know what to do dude he told me
and I didn't know what to do this
probably out maybe 11 years ago and I
remember taking one of my fingers brawny
joking and just put it into his mouth
off of 23rd Street over there in Santa
Monica by the park and I don't was it I
don't even know why and he laughed and I
kind of laughed effort but I just didn't
know the / certain interactions you know
how to behave during it someone falls
down a stair you know where someone
falls off the back of a um you know the
back of a of a building ever one story
of a ranch-style home you know what to
do you go you run over you help you put
your hair you put both arms on them are
you okay what's up you know somebody
walks up to you says hello you know how
to do it you shake their hand you put
your hand out they put their hand out
that's a shake
that's a meeting of hands each person
brings one hand to the meeting but they
don't tell you how what to do if
somebody comes out of the closet they
don't give you how do you behave how do
you just stick you late that what do you
do with your arms when somebody comes
out of the closet and I didn't know I
just didn't know what to do I just
remember taking one of my fingers just
put it right in his mouth dude and it
was a neighbor said it was a natural
reaction it wasn't a choice I made it
was a non choice that I did but that's
something that could change people do
something what el now what do you do
maybe take somebody's temperature and
slap him maybe you start smelling them
you smelled it back at her pants like a
baby you know I don't know what it's
anything could be you know things are
gonna change another call came in things
are gonna change possibly this is Ryan
what up Ryan what the f baby what's up
oh yeah brother
and you sound fired up buddy boy you've
been having Red Bull or any or something
homeward
the new normal that's all this going on
and one of the things I remember hearing
on on some news radios into the other
day outdoor concerts and festivals
things like that they're starting to
experiment with like they want to slide
new drones over the top of the concert
and these drones are gonna have like
infrared sensors that can tell if
someone's hot and they can see if
someone's running hotter than the rest
of the concert goers so they're gonna
fly these drones up they're gonna pick
people out and then whatever the
security there is gonna go walk up to
them be like hey we got to pull you
outside take your temperature whatever
something like that Wow
yeah I could see it you out there
enjoying a little well in Elson you know
or a little uh you know Megan the
stallion or something or big Meg or
whatever you know you out there Joe
enjoying a little bit of skinny Adele
and next thing you know they release a
batch of hot hunters just just they got
they just temperature drones just a
bunch of damn frickin Fahrenheit Falcons
just nibbling at you and you got one
buddy he's hot brah he's hot but he
still wants to party he's on a couple
hits of acid you know and he's you know
he just he's deep deep you know when
he's listening to [ __ ] he's at one
concert but he's listening to another
concert only on headphones you know he's
at widespread panic but he's listening
to Michael Jackson on his ear pods he's
on two hits of acid and he's running
high on temperature and body temp and
he's he's saying hey guys hide me hide
me cover me cuz he don't want one of
them one of them electronic temperature
birds coming and getting him and then
the bouncers come over the heat bouncers
what's up man are you hard bro
it used to be you got to be hot to get
in the club now if you
you got to get out the club it's full
circle hey we need some ice-cold [ __ ]
man dude only cold [ __ ] only I'm
talking about real legitimate [ __ ]
from Norway
Nordic Greenland Iceland let me get that
Antarctica
girl bring her to the club most she only
88 degrees man that she could stay in
hell she could be an investor she could
be a silent investor it's gonna be cold
people only at the club people will be
wearing ice around their neck real ice
diamonds and [ __ ] bro I need I need 14
degree gold do you have that that's what
I need because it's gonna change
everything's gonna change is it though I
mean look do I really think it is I
really do not I really do not I think I
really think that we've taken a good
measure of trying to battle this virus I
think we've taken a really good measure
I also think it's time to get things
back going and there's some people like
life will never be the same you know
some people like men you will never
children will be born in incubator you
won't you won't even see your child till
he's seven you'll oh don't you you'll
never go on a date you're crazy
you'll never wash your own ass boy you
will never wash your own ass boy you
little freak
you little you little [ __ ] but that's
not true I think things gonna go back
very normal I really do I really really
do here's another call that came in uh
uh uh you guys have so many great ideas
man as always the hotline is nine eight
five six six four nine five
0/3 you guys had so many interesting
interesting things that could happen you
know that could happen ohm word Yossi oh
my name is Chris Jones and from Des
Moines what's up Chris Jones and I used
to know a fella named Toby Jones or
actually Chris Jones was his name and
they call him Toby and he was real real
white in his eyes his eyes was always
open pretty wide you know he kind of had
those eyes where you know he would tell
you he was going to sleep but you didn't
believe him you were like no way and he
had a real he was a young fella that
lived by me growing up and he was kind
of tough he was a rapscallion and he
wore kind of large shirts that were
collared and just a damn large shirt and
sometime his shirt was so big he'd go
inside he'd be like look man I'll be
right back and he would just go inside
of his shirt
what where is he and he come back out
and have a licorice or have a UH um a
Jolly Rancher like damn where the shirts
come with a damn kitchenette but they
called him Toby and he was a good friend
when I was young and he was a good kid
and and I enjoyed um I enjoyed living in
the same neighborhood as that boy gonna
all word coma just kind of an experience
um with this whole coronavirus thing
that I don't think anyone's called in
with yet or at least I haven't heard it
um so my uncle passed away a couple
weeks ago oh damn man sorry to hear that
brother and r.i.p to his beautiful last
brother and i'm sure he was a good man
brother and uh you know it's
it's an interesting journey of life
because you can die that's the real
caveat Oh word oh good I'm not betting
out of shape about it really too much or
anything he was a good dude at Stage
four colon cancer and he fought it for
two and a half years yeah oh man can you
I mean I cannot even fathom brother
fighting something that is you know
fighting something that is in your own
ass that is um you know that's like a
level that's like that's like a Zelda or
that we'll never know about I mean that
is the ultimate Mortal Kombat really is
fighting a curious disease that is
inside of your own ass body ass ass you
know what I'm talking my butt mm-hmm and
I'm sorry to hear that brother yeah my
father passed away a colon cancer too
and it's you know it's crazy to think
that something could be in your ass that
doesn't like you or that doesn't want
you to be alive onward you know my
family was mainly grateful for that and
so he was in Kansas City in Kansas City
there still shut down they couldn't have
more than you know however many people
in the building for the funeral and he
has five kids and his wife and then the
pastor and the videographer and all that
because they were putting the funeral on
YouTube so long story short my dad
didn't even get to go to the funeral
none of us were able to go to funeral
his kids were able to and his wife was
able to and everything we just watched
his funeral on YouTube just a couple
hours ago Wow
so they YouTube and death you know the
Grim Reaper is is upgrading his
technology that's what it's come to
people the Grim Reaper is upgrading his
technology
gee okay this man have to be somewhere
watching his uncle died on a damn
YouTube homeward and it was just it was
just kind of a trip it was just really
weird and I'm like the the emotion
wasn't really there watching this
funeral on YouTube and even for my dad
it was just it just wasn't quite the
same he even said something about it
just you know the human brain maybe
processing that kind of emotion
differently I don't know man just kind
of weird I'm very sorry to hear about
the the passing in your family and I'm
really sorry for your dad you know
you know I got to see my brother this
weekend in out there and so you tanned
it's you know it's a special gift to
have a brother and I'm a man I bet that
was really tough for him but jeepers
jeepers friend I when you hear this and
you know uh you know how are you gonna
be on you woody for in the middle of a
thing yeah you know you get an email
reminder or a notification of a damn
tick-tock or something and you you know
they were sitting there right there you
know rent you know you know Johnny was a
good man and he he survived today by and
then it's like you know what if somebody
comments on the thing Gang Gang first
what if somebody writes that on the
frickin funeral you know it just
hmm yeah that mean that's just a crate
you know somebody writes first on your
on your uncle's funeral or somebody
writes like oh I thought this was magic
and I thought they were gonna cut the
thing in half or something just I mean
the way it's all it all could get wild
it all could get wild those are some
great some great suggestions man some
great thoughts about what - what could
happen what could the work of the world
be light evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was ok but
the next video you can watch could be
way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one